[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
no no not everyone
please be seated executive vice
president Madigan faculty colleagues
alumni masters candidates and their
families and friends good afternoon and
welcome to convocation for masters
candidates in the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences I thank all of you for
coming to celebrate the many
accomplishments of our masters
candidates we honor today a magnificent
group that on commencement this coming
Wednesday will join the ranks of our
close to 40,000 alumni and who will
embark on professional and academic
careers around the world in the great
tradition of Columbia University equally
important we also honor in the ceremony
the families and friends of our
candidates and today especially the
mothers among them
who have endured with them the rigors of
their academic pursuits thank you for
being so supportive and understanding I
would also ask all masters candidates to
rise and applaud those friends and
family members who have helped them to
be here today
the student remarks to the graduating
class will be offered by Jonah or theis
[Applause]
well mr. Ortiz graduates today with an
MA in political science he graduated
last year from King's College the new
york city in new york city with a degree
in politics philosophy and economics
during his time as a graduate and
undergraduate student his research and
writing have focused in on 1960s
american politics politics and the
recent rise of populism he hopes to
apply his studies of politics to a life
of public service mr. Ortiz
well thank you dean Alonso for that very
kind introduction
dear executive vice president Madigan
faculty and staff friends family and the
ma class of 2018 after spending much of
my life dreaming of going to a school
like Columbia but never thinking it
would be possible it is difficult to
express how both delightful and
surprising this moment feels I would
like to share this moment and use this
moment to share my thoughts on the
challenges that face us as a graduating
class and how I believe that our time at
Columbia has best prepared us to meet
them while we may come from different
disciplines and backgrounds one common
thread that unites us all is belief by
belief I'm not referring to religion
faith or ideology but something more
human than that an abiding trust and a
hope in ourselves in each other and in
things we cannot yet see I'm talking
about the belief we had on ourselves
when we applied to Columbia and the
belief that our families including our
mothers had in us shone through their
encouragement I'm speaking of the belief
that our professors having us the
commitment and care that they showed to
us in class and in office hours
bequeathing to us their passions I'm
referring to the belief that we have in
our fellow students alongside whom we
studied late into the night in the
library belief in ourselves and in our
future is precisely why we have
undertaken all of these challenges
belief is the lifeblood of this
university belief is also the basis of
the bonds in our society
belief in our institutions and our
scholars our artists and each other help
keeps our world together that bond has
been fraying as belief has been eroding
in the United States as well as much of
the rest of the world belief in our
institutions our government our leaders
and our laws are at historic lows in
this fake news era belief in the media
has similarly crumbled with basic
conceptions of truth being called into
question even as our scientists and
scholars produce better and better
research public trust in that research
has been strained with scientific facts
often be ignored in public debates
perhaps most concerning of all has been
the erosion of belief in one another and
in ourselves with our technological
advances our world should be closer than
ever before but too often it feels as if
we could not be more alone and more
alienated from one another too often we
view those different from us with
cynicism and suspicion we're on a fast
and dangerous course that is narrowed
our understanding of us while broadening
our understanding of them and that
course has manifested itself in
previously unimaginable ways we're still
in face of the rising currents of this
sea of cynicism we lose belief in
ourselves and in our capacity to make a
difference how then shall we face these
challenges what we cannot do is to
surrender to this cynicism and remain
safe within the comforting walls of
familiarity the professors at Columbia
I have mosa drama a most admired
reminded me the pint every bit of
research and data is life in whatever we
do we must remain engaged with the world
on the campus and the lab no natural
scientists should ever forget the
splendor of nature nor should any
scientists or scholar of the humanities
lose sight of humanity itself given the
opportunities we have been granted we
must always ask what more we can be
doing for others to meet this challenge
I believe what is first required is
understanding if we wish to see the
bonds of belief made whole again in this
world we must first do so by our own
example we must be willing to listen to
those who are different from us and to
use all of our scholarly skills of
discernment to discern the humanity in
each other and in so doing live in a
spirit of patience of understanding and
of love second we must never forget the
opportunities given to us by a Columbia
education fewer than 1% of all people of
all time have ever been given an
opportunity such as this and as much as
our hard work has helped us arrive here
we had nothing to do with being in a
circumstance where hard work could yield
a Columbia education somewhere there are
people with our same yearnings our same
abilities but because of circumstance
they could not have this opportunity we
must not ever forget that
that is why finally I believe that our
graduating class must not only
appreciate these opportunities but that
we have an obligation to make use of
them as we were given the chance to live
out our dreams of learning here we ought
to continue to dream big and in the
words of our University's founder Samuel
Johnson clear our minds of the word
can't
for scientists that means pursuing the
research closest to your heart and
proposing the project's not that bear
the promise of peer approval or career
advancement but that reflects your
conscious and that you believe are the
most noble and daring because you
believe they are worth while and ought
to be ventured for those of you who wish
to teach teach not where is most
comfortable for our students must
require your wisdom and your learning
for those who wish to go into public
service and activism do not give in to
cynicism or despair but instead remember
the words of dr. King that now is always
the time to do what is right that is a
future worth the work that brought us
here worth the opportunity given to us
and is worth believing in our lives are
far too short to believe in anything
less that is the same spirit of hope and
belief that guided so many lives of
Columbia's previous graduates that is
how in that same spirit an immigrant who
was young scrappy and Hungary managed to
rise from Columbia to the Capitol and
inspired a Broadway musical it's with
that spirit that in 1952 a Columbia ma
graduate later went on to become the
first black woman elected to the United
States Congress it was with that spirit
that a young woman a refugee from
Czechoslovakia later graduated from
Columbia and went on to become Secretary
of State making the world a more
peaceful place and is with that same
spirit that 14 years ago an
eight-year-old boy unsure of whether he
had the means or the abilities to even
go to college could tell himself that it
didn't matter that he never met anyone
who went to an Ivy League school because
one day he would be speaking
to the graduating master's class of
Columbia University in 2018 and it thank
and in following that spirit and that
belief at a future graduation years from
now let it be said of our class and our
generation that we in the words of
Harlem's great Langston Hughes became
the builders of the temples of tomorrow
strong as we know how let it be said
that when we built those temples of
tomorrow in classrooms and boardrooms in
streets and Senate halls let it be said
that we built them with care and that we
built them with heart and with loud love
and that we built them because it was
hard let it be said of us that we built
them like Columbia graduates let it be
said today and for all time that we are
Columbia graduates and a Columbia the
future is always your story to write and
so you can tell the world that we are
ready to shed our cynicism and stand
together and with our eyes forever fixed
on the horizon we are ready to hope we
are ready to dream and yes we are ready
to believe again thank you everyone for
giving me this chance and
congratulations my fellow graduates I
love you all thank you
I will vote for him
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Ortiz today's keynote
address will be offered by David Madigan
executive vice president for the Arts
and Sciences Dean of the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences and professor of statistics
professor Madigan received his BA in
mathematical sciences and a PhD in
statistics both from Trinity College in
Dublin he has taught at the University
of Washington and at Rutgers University
he has authored more than 140
publications in such areas as Bayesian
statistics text mining Monte Carlo
methods
pharmacovigilance and probabilistic
graphical models he's an elected fellow
of the American Statistical Association
the Institute of mathematical statistics
and the American Association for the
Advancement of science the American
concludes this year a very successful
five year stint as executive vice
president for the Arts and Sciences in
which he managed five schools 27
departments and more than 50 research
centers and Institute's at Columbia no
wonder he looks so happy he has
sustained and strengthened the school's
academic excellence and expanded its
interdisciplinary programs and
international partnerships executive
vice president Madigan
well thank you very much for your kind
welcome that's one tough act to follow
that was quite extraordinary not vote
for you to dean Alonso promise Colts
worth assembled faculty students and
guests I am deeply honored and somewhat
surprised to have this opportunity to
address you today
first and foremost congratulations to
the 2018 graduating class and also to
all the grandparents parents spouses
partners and their children who I know
played a critical role in helping this
amazing group of graduates get to this
point in their lives and especially
thank you to your mother's I have no
doubt that you will be extraordinary
leaders of your professions and I
personally can offer little advice about
your career trajectories maybe what I
can do is offer some words of advice not
just as leaders in your field which
undoubtedly you will be but more broadly
as leaders in a global society
the first thing a good leader should
have is a healthy appreciation and
understanding of our moment in history
from where I stand we seem to be in a
unique moment massive changes in
technology that is not only disrupting
existing professions and entire
industries but are creating entirely new
industries that were unimaginable just a
few years ago fundamental changes in how
we communicate to one another as well as
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of people did you know that Katy Perry
has a hundred and nine million followers
on Twitter just ahead of Justin Beiber
and Barack Obama and there's on her
unheard-of wealth creation with
individuals amassing more wealth than at
any other moment in time with that we
have some of the highest levels of
income inequality and political
polarization is this 2018 yes
but it also describes 1918 if you recall
massive changes in technology gasoline
engines electricity the birth of new
industries like ultra Beals and
telecommunications millions migrating to
urban
areas fundamental changes in
communication at that time telegraph
telephone radio moving images and the
ability to communicate to millions of
people unheard of wealth creation
Rockefeller JP Morgan Carnegie etc
income inequality was at one of its
highest points in 1918 what's my point
yes our moment is unique but we must be
keen students of history to understand
our own world my singular advice to you
is to read read voraciously read history
read poetry read novels read biographies
read at every opportunity
reading connects us to a world of ideas
and experiences reading is central to a
good life but what am i doing up here
giving you advice I grew up in a small
town in Ireland a far cry from this
August Ivy League institution and every
so often have to pinch myself to make
sure this is actually real every so
often I figure they'll catch up to me
and discover that I'm the same kid that
grew up on the 2 Mile Road in that alone
and played soccer badly and couldn't
dance to save his life and they're gonna
turf me out of my ear but they haven't
caught up to me yet over the years I've
listened to about I think about 50
commencement addresses my favorite one
of all was last year at this podium the
great soccer leader and economics
teacher Sunil Gulati and he started his
remarks by saying that he hadn't
received an advanced copy of Dean
Alonso's remarks to come and they were
so good he was just going to use those I
watched the blood drained from Dean
Alonso's face at that at that moment
so in these commencement addresses
cliches seem to be de rigueur so I'll
offer one to accept I'll do mine as
gaeilge whose SMAW is Latin he bruh
are there any grail Gore's out there in
the audience who know what I just said a
hand or two went up roughly speaking a
good start is half the work if something
is worth doing or saying don't
procrastinate do it and do it with
enthusiasm and gusto
don't fail from the want of trying as I
look back over my life my big regrets
concerned the things I didn't do or say
be authentic be yourself in the words of
Steve Jobs your time is limited so don't
waste it living someone else's life
don't let the noise of others opinions
drown out your inner voice and most
important have the courage to follow
your heart and intuition I personally
don't believe in grand plans and at the
age of 55 I still haven't figured out
what I want to be when I grow up I
believe in passionate dedication to
short and medium-term goals put your
head down and work with pride on
whatever is in front of you be careful
of long term dreams and in the words of
the great comedian Tim Minchin if you
focus too far in front of you you won't
see the shiny thing out of the corner of
your eye let me make some very brief
remarks about about the emergence of big
data and data science which will
profoundly impact all of you the
inexorable rise of computing and
large-scale data storage has impacted
most human activities sometimes in
profound ways financial markets for
instance which many of you have studied
generate rivers of intensely scrutinized
data all major global scale retailers
store and analyze vast quantities of
customer and transaction data and many
areas of research as diverse as
astronomy and zoology have become
largely data-driven this trend is
universal and unstoppable we live in a
world where it costs $500 to buy a disk
drive that can store all of the world's
music we're 15 out of seven the 17
sectors of the US economy have more data
stored per company than the Library of
Congress and where there are 30 billion
pieces of content shared on Facebook
every month for sure there are some
sinister and dark aspects to all of this
some of which we've seen in the last few
weeks but the potential to harness data
to provide evidence-based solutions to
some of the world's most pressing and
urgent problems is immense your
generation cannot dodge this
I urge you to embrace this trend become
an expert on what you can technically
and ethically do with what you can and
cannot do with with data spoken as a
statistician to wrap up while I do not
know what the future will bring
observing the longer arc of our
collective history and getting to know
the amazing students graduating from
this special home that we call Columbia
I am hugely optimistic for the future
the brightest and the best come to
Columbia and we faculty have an enormous
responsibility to do well by you I hope
we have done so now you have the
responsibility to go forth and do good
in the world I know the future will be
in excellent hands thank you and warm
congratulations to the graduating class
of 2018 thank you
Thank You executive vice-president
batygin we now arrive at the central
point of the ceremony the presentation
of the Masters candidates we ask you to
come forth as we call your name in
recognition of your individual
accomplishments
Schank Ishii senior lecturer in Chinese
will read the names of the MA candidates
as they cross the stage
receiving a master's of ours in
african-american studies Daniel
Bareilles Armstrong taming caring Scott
receiving a Master of Arts in American
Studies julissa Pena
[Applause]
Janina Wilson but our Deen you can yak
[Music]
amber Thomas
Ashley whoo Joshua good Mark Richards
Stein receiving a Master of Arts in
anthropology Roubini Naidu Deborah
Phillips
Adrian D'Elia sterling what man has all
your do move and Cecil Darin jongmyo
Goten Hmong
Luo Tian
Adam you receiving a Master of Arts in
art history and ecology
mark-paul Tori Schmidt jus lash you in
war Sarah
Bigler Julia Reno's receiving a Master
of Arts in biomed biomedical informatics
meowy Shin Kamiya nursey
Margaret's scene
John wait she Chen lo hacen I team
receiving a Master of Arts in
biotechnology frank de vita salar come
chat Mo's Eric host Lauren QJ Philippa
Jones Carina Robin Eva a real dream Berg
Maria if fine
as aunt Chopra
Catherine Hafner Alice whole arena
Coolidge in Cova Michael caught hold
we're Nicky Nicko Lackey
Avena gusta vulva
Neha and salmon Nadia Malik MIDI ha
Selim Geelong Hashem go in
King John chili Edwards chain Christine
hi
charcoal hmong yang
Alejandro Garcia Diaz
[Applause]
[Music]
Derek white Jo Whiley receive a mass of
ours in classical studies Jared metonic
receive a Master of Arts in classics
Polina God which Jason Reno's Kathleen
Morgan
liyan Bankia receive a mass of ours in
climate and society you beam you home
chun-hyang
ng halt yelling Sabrina halt
for more young
take away ahem
Jade page
[Music]
[Applause]
Avalon Hawk spawns Dina for Rome
Dominic does soul
[Music]
Anju angle Rebecca
katha chef Kerry lung Anna
Simo Italian fellow Nerissa Turner
Madeline Lloyd amantha
Sofia import ever thought she among
Anastasia ELISA bread Ali money
Ashley Bay Shira
Josh he me know him
sorry him a new foe fum Zika Morales
Angela Soriano
kivett Oh Lara Hoffman Hernandez Lavanya
horse
Miriam missiles David um
brian daniel ho lems Sarah's
jig Castleman we seen a mass of ours in
Earth and Environmental Sciences jungle
watching Yuna Miller
Megan Franco show you sing receiving a
mass of ours in East Asia regional
studies chun-li Olli cha-cha-cha young
wait Han Lee machine Joslyn a dijah
tackler Nicholas bring hold Leo utrom
Selene Hanshaw
Salim Kim
receive a Master of Arts in East Asian
languages and cultures
iris Kim Theresa Caputo
ding yang Jennifer Reno's strange
Catherine Caputo Scott Miller
hi sergeant choung you chuan Chung Chung
Iran lordy
[Music]
Chen Xiao Chun LAN Xin looming see Li
Jie
yo lon Emily Cho we see me a master of
arts in conservation biology Lauren
Naylor Jessica Espinoza clear ghosts
[Applause]
Jessica hawk
Alexander Proctor protein Christina
Rivera a prison Rivera
[Music]
Neha savant
we seem a Master of Arts in economics
the China Sea
using ten
receive a massive arse in English and
comparative literature Marcelo Castro
Salinas Tyler Huxtable Brad beau
Macmillan Samantha Yee
you spell Guan Florence on
Kieran Rock Priscilla soul Mikayla Brown
Naomi rose
how Wow how long Sandra Abramovich we
seem a mass of ours in European history
politics and a society Sarah
Roth Stephanie sunken Daniel Castro
Caitlin shine Brandon Allen
angel - tada
we seen a mass of ours in Germanic
languages Casey
Moyer receive a mass of ours in global
thought Alexandra Hetalia Bianca
sanabria Lucia epic quest any champion
[Applause]
rips him rip see me Bianca Michelle as
lania men Polynesian Beluga or do 40
[Applause]
Leah Nina Liana Carol
Alejandro Carillo morning
Gutierrez McCoy pretty Jane who Angeline
UNK Moshe young Marvin our road of
Valenti
Baima angel Rhine
Julia the angle
Lara coke sama Weber
[Applause]
mahsa Sitaram Aditi charter receive a
mass of ours in history and literature
am Li Chiao Elizabeth Turner
Chloe rose Crabtree
[Music]
Hank up meridian
[Applause]
Anna run flash ring flash Thomas Jolie
we seen the mass of ours in Human Rights
studies a Catina a a catenary kasuri
[Applause]
Amanda
Graham holy havens Jessica Pearson Julia
chicolini Rovira hustle hustle
Aaron McGee
Lily jig hope
Kathleen Richardson Sofia
Nagi
[Applause]
Karen Ingrid's dyani l regio any Nome
Abramoff Jacqueline Martin seventies
Shibani Savannah noggin
Patrice brown
affinia schoolin Navitus
[Applause]
hana Holroyd Barbara Matias
my real Quesada
[Applause]
Jeffrey white
Elizabeth he needs zero Michelle - nard
snart
shan-pak Yami Manucci
pegye Malik Ahmadi Jennifer minutes
Bharat
Christine Claus Alexander Seaver
Jennifer Homburg
we seem a mass of ours in international
and war history
Addison Bailey Joseph De Rosa
Jasmine poet ho t Afra Wong Sally
Greenland
we seem a mass of ours in Italian Taylor
Kali Laurie we see a mass of ours in
Javanese pedagogy a yaku Anderson Atsuko
Onuma we see a mass of ours in Jewish
Studies Alison richer's we seem a mass
of ours in Latin America and the
Caribbean grow better polity Song Ji
Yong
then shorts
[Applause]
nafech Oh Nancy neele
Lawrence Benjamin woods China Castro
Charlie's Espinosa receive a mass of
ours in Latin American and I billion by
burning cultures Briana Gutierrez we
seem a mass of ours in mathematics of
finest citrine bagel
pierre-antoine bored
Matthew Ivaldi
tge
Mao means yet
Dileep Singh Jung Hyun Jung won one year
transit she
jeong-ja
changhie hunter-reay pinky
jeong-seon Wang Qin
Samuel Kovac ran
uma Gopalakrishnan Chun Xu Jia Chauncey
don't go boy Zhang Han Qi among young
near Shu young
something to to each hand
who was shoot yet one team Lee Mong
Cheng
once is ready
Joe Chun LAN chanting
you shall you
generally none
1e when
Lutie
Leo you home
Bingley Wang Yao receiving a Master of
Arts in Medieval and Renaissance Studies
each Tama
alumni Christina Krishna van
Jason Lawrence boned
we see me a masters or a master for
hours in middle middle eastern South
Asia and African Studies Sheriff Parag
[Music]
Sita Ram Siri harem receiving a mass of
Arts in Modern Art's critical and
accurate curatorial studies Shimane
branch one bang where it's Englehart
[Applause]
Madeleine whispered Weisberg Olivia casa
Addison person
[Applause]
Marie huh Kalin Maria Kalin Geoffrey
Paul Addison Canella receiving a Master
of Arts in modern European studies Mayer
horn we seen a Master of Arts in
European history politics and society
Tristan secret Seacrest
we seen a Master of Arts in modern
European studies
Melissa wholesome receive a mass of ours
in Museum anthropology Thalia a mother
Elenita Nicholas we seem a mass of ours
the oral history Desmond Austin Miller
Samantha Lombard lien Lewis
[Applause]
Tomoko yamoto earlene Kalfas Philip
Mazurek
we seen a mass of ours in kalasa pu.1
cassia mattoon Otto
alexia trigo
can you sing ritual the efan Anthony
Mars we see a mass of ours in physics
Kylie
Kennedy receive a mass of Arts in
political science
John shulie eaching love Jason Cooper
hey young limb
Michael we love God aboah go Doba Eric
bender
Gina perigee karate
[Applause]
Margaret's bands
Victoria tinker Sanchi rice shocker
[Applause]
Dave a she division sing path Shaw but
yeah ramani when an Rachel Norwalk
[Music]
[Applause]
Courtney Lockington jasmiyah from Ray
Alicia Maurice Kapoor raw George Patrick
[Applause]
Jonah Ortiz receive a Master of Arts in
psychology Manisa de would receive a
mass of ours in quantitative methods in
the social sciences Emma Gabor Oh Nathan
covered Connor Worman
Tom brunella tan Whelan Christina Yaakov
vines
Nara amad Nicole Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
Rebecca Seco Sophie buyers
[Music]
yang Qin
Nathan fabulous
lee jung chan yuen-han hon Hana Cordova
Thomas brahim nozzle parody tardes
Sammy gasps
[Applause]
trevor sector malari armbands
supa Suri
[Applause]
jonathan levine Thal g cop jet person
Hajek mark
[Music]
David Medina Hernandez okay who sue our
sushi engine sea otter Chang Ybor one
Kuwait
[Applause]
so we how you young son xuxian Yahya
Shabbat or lung ya doin Kim Soo yung him
Hana Chung
Amy Yamada Yamaha one one team in
gentian so issue Tutsi
mount yunshan salmon rim remain firmly
[Music]
Nikki caught a charm
[Applause]
Dana crusher
Jonathan Campbell Jen Hwan doin Panditji
[Applause]
Chen Wei Tran
young long phone
[Applause]
sua da and and nice and we seem a mass
of ours in volition Dillon Schneider
[Music]
mammoth odds up Robert grab awaits
Casa McGowen
Taylor Congo amny Churchill
receive a mass of ours in Russia Eurasia
and in East Europe Business Studies
David Troodon Jack Stein William person
[Applause]
Andres Hernandez Octavia Kishan Bose
kiri matures we seem a mass of ours in
Islamic cultures Anna Percy Cola we seem
a Master of Arts in Islamic languages
Alfred Rosenberg we seen a mass of ours
in Slavic cultures Hannah Miller
receiving a mass of ours in sociology
jamming tongue Millar Ogden she's
humming Christine oven oven wah
[Music]
Tiffany Martinez
[Applause]
I alia sauna K supper
Sam donar
[Music]
Alexandra Alina Guido Piazza Samuel Ruth
Ruth and thoughts
Dakota rose Cabrera
Sara chamois
Jonathan Cleveland receive a mass of
ours in South Asia studies
Mabini shop cart
Justin Joseph fight a Marine we seen a
Master of Arts in statistics see online
Louie M Bing Lee Shahan swamp Owen
Lizzy seen
don't through Hong Li she hung
who is Yong Yong TMG Lee Changmin
one you don't want any one youthful lean
Han should xi'an
Chen Chen Jian
they are young tan tan-tan yeah yeah
okay you little poor young home soo
young cha cha boy yeah
we eat one Guangzhou
haengju again one year change agent
young in her
her 1:1 mob or sure young chef Anne
Joji hyung alejandro quito's lima
[Applause]
John King Kelly hora de pollo lady real
ricardo Palmer
[Music]
a man Valachi
[Applause]
enric Malou
so been year
sunshine will
calab Kira here a lie highlight sorry
be changing
thousand she won Lanzhou one jar year
young ye
chanting Chen Leo Joey you seen Liu
Chang Jung Seng
Kwang soo Chien
full year
to her tenkai
jeongmi Samantha nebith
Leo Chen
not job
come fan how shuya yangchen leave soon
she alone young songyang
Jen Holmes here
young you mean leading Sammy Salonika
Helen Lee none
fine one humble hanta one can ye pouting
home million
nope a loop
Karen Jeong
tanjo year 10 million saluting Hanukkah
palmarosa should see you dancing
[Applause]
Thailand ye ending when some truthful
banjo chan chan salut Joey
Johnson UN
no senior food don't weigh her UT
kkoma claim the one
one city we are team
hurry to choose your you will see see
you in Chile anyway
come on yeah
Yong Chun Chun charging so you see Louis
in
soo-ji Mirko scene
cool when you're lunching
my team boy
one Singh who shall Sooey
Luud singing Jang ye receive a Master of
Arts in theatre Kathryn suffering
[Applause]
and now my closing remarks to the
graduating class with the procession of
scholars across this stage today you
have been treated to the seemingly
inexhaustible variety of fields and
departments encompassed by the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences at Columbia
yet regardless of the discipline in
which you will receive your master's
degree this coming Wednesday what you
have learned during your stay here has
not been just a way of asking questions
about particular objects but the
discipline of interrogation itself hence
you should be proud of and faithful to
what you have learned here but the
discipline of asking questions requires
that you not be so proud of and so
faithful to that knowledge that you'll
be unable to critique the very education
you have acquired in this institution in
order to be continually open to the new
you must be able to take your distance
from the presumed necessity of what you
have learned here to challenge the very
things that define you as belonging to
your academic origins to entertain at
every turn the possibility of
self-imposed exile from your
disciplinary home it will be as such
moments that you will renew the
legitimacy of the degree that you're
about to receive and the trust that this
institution has deposited in you by
granting it at such moments it will be
worth remembering that you were
conferred this degree so you will ask
questions critically doggedly and
unsparingly even if the one not spared
be yourself
in fact the kind of openness to the new
that I'm invoking and the vigilance
required for it to manifest manifest
itself continually in your scholarly
life he's learned every single day in
the negotiation of all the experiences
with which life will present you all the
daily instances in which our capacity to
confront change or to become the agent
for change will be challenged not just
but by what is new and unforeseen for
even more forcefully and dangerously by
what is customary and what is expected
of you the vexing gift that your
Columbia graduate occasion has given you
will require you to continuously
entertain in your mind the most radical
thought experiments what if the world
were otherwise than it is what if you
should not be whom you thought you
should be and then to reimagine both the
world and yourself anew it is the gift
that keeps on taking that continually
makes ever larger demands of you
remember that you were methodically
trained to be an agent of new
understanding and that preserving the
authority of received knowledge is
decidedly not the reason why Columbia
will hand you a graduate degree next
Wednesday
today surrounded by the community of
your graduate colleagues faculty mentors
and family members and despite the toil
and sacrifices of your graduate years
you begin what in reality will be your
most arduous and solitary assignment yet
keeping your intellectual life of flame
on your own and allowing it to consume
everything even your most cherished
ideas and believe
this is the thorny rose the sweet
burning without Circe's that your
graduate education at Columbia has given
you as a gift and the one that you will
henceforth have to nurture rigorously
and lovingly by yourself
we at the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences know that you will take
meticulous care of this demanding and
thorny intellectual gift we arrive then
at the end of this magnificent
magnificent ceremony go forth to be our
representatives and emissaries to the
world and all of us at Columbia will
rejoice in your inevitable achievements
prosper and prevail make us and your
relatives and friends prouder still
about you than we are today
will the candidates please stand so we
may give them a final round of applause
all of you are invited to a champagne
reception immediately following this
ceremony at Avery Plaza under the tent
I asked friends and families to wait to
exit until after the faculty and the
candidates have ascended the low library
steps
[Music]